the gyro can experience a lot of people
believe it's a controlled demolition I
don't think necessarily she is saying
that it is or it isn't and I and I
certainly am NOT I don't know I don't
understand you know what I believe more
it was a controlled demolition yes but
with it by us yes
oh yeah I mean thanked I think that's
always been the case of the the argument
I don't think it was done by the
terrorists right they think see honey no
no building to the tear wouldn't know
what if the terrorists oh if they did a
control - and yeah it wasn't like if
somehow they had tears I mean if the
terrace probably could easily I think I
would probably before hijacking planes
and flying them into buildings before
that would be putting a bomb in the
building yes it's not that easy see like
when you see what would happen in
Oklahoma City
dad that was multiple bombs you know in
Oklahoma City they actually there was
all these reports of the FBI removing
bombs from the building like that didn't
explode and if you talk to these guys
that are demolition experts they say
there's no way that was a fertilizer
bomb there's no fucking way right like
they would they said that if you look at
the amount of damage that did and look
at where the blast radius is from the
way he blows out it doesn't blow they're
not designed it and you're saying yeah
that's building because we've all seen
the loose change work you watch the
lights go off around the building yeah
like one floor by one yeah but see they
don't know that see they don't know what
that means though that also could be if
the ceiling is coming in and slamming
into the floor all the windows would do
that they don't know that that's
explosions if it really was collapsing
like that see no one's ever seen a
building collapse like that so when they
say that those are blips and those are
squibs I don't like that because then
I'm saying you're saying you know for
sure what that is and I'm saying the
fuck you do I don't know even even
someone's got it just because someone
has to know I'm not saying it was as I'm
not saying it was an inside job it just
seems odd ergonomically that you would
design a building that if impacted at a
certain point the entire thing would
demolish like what structurally what
purpose does that serve well the we are
yeah the weird look could just be
incompetence that's possible if you look
at humans that's our most likely option
right I mean when does they make your
World Trade Center so fucking long as
time ago the
get so cocky to build a building that's
100 goddamn storeys high right and how
long did they think that was gonna stay
up there for you know what if it started
falling apart and rotting what it was
they're just so just a wonky piece of
shit by the time we got hit by those
planes yeah that's totally true I mean
yeah this fucking thing was old as shit
that thing was around that's black and
white television essica Lion King Kong I
mean yeah but what's retro fishiness
the cheapest goddamn floor and the
cheapest got bitter you know that you do
that how many for it with bombs well
that's the crazy idea what we're saying
about building seven or more the other
building like terrorists could have done
it I mean I guess they could have but
how the fuck are they gonna get in there
and put all those explosives in it's
like dynamite a time there's red sticks
of dynamite one of a sign up your ass
you're working the fucking thing five
years in this closet
sticks you're walking down the hallway
you just smell shit open this door
what's in this just smells like shit and
it says shitty dynamite sticks it's like
a fucking log house built with shit and
dynamite sticks yeah and little Harris
he matric a pee mattress